welcome to the church of what's
happening now
this episode is brought to you by
blue apron for less than ten dollars per
meal
blue apron will deliver seasonal recipes
along with proportion ingredients to
make delicious home-cooked meal
each meal comes with a step-by-step
easy to follow recipe card and
pre-proportioned ingredients and it can
be prepared in 40 minutes or less who's
better than you
check out this week's menu and get your
first three meals for free by going to
blueapron.com
joey again check out this week's menu
and get your first three meals for free
with free shipping by going to
blueapron.com
joey
let me ask you guys the questions we all
want to eat better but when it comes to
snacks you're sitting there late night
watching tv
the whole world
is delicious and it's got a billion
calorie versus boring and tasteless it
doesn't have to be that way up your
snack game with nature box jack let me
tell you something nature box has over
100 snacks that taste good and actually
better for you all snacks are made with
high quality simple ingredients which
means no artificial colors flavors
sweeteners so you can feel good about
what you're eating and right now i'm
even going to save you some more dory
meat nature box is offering my family
you guys three free snacks with your
first order when you go to naturebox.com
joey again that's naturebox.com
joey for three free snacks with your
first order
naturebox.com
joey also
to my main brothers over there on it
they're over there pedaling
nature uh
uh
hem force protein
you got the shroom tech sport you got
the alpha brain
listen alpha brain is so good they got a
money-back guarantee and they don't even
want the goddamn product back when
somebody believes in their products so
much
what are you gonna do go to honor.com
right now and press in church bam and
get 10 off let's get this [ __ ]
started
i'm going to the on at gym
me too
oh [ __ ]
revenge
what it's monday [ __ ]
polish that dick
and get those [ __ ] socks cleaned up
it's gonna be a good week
need some
what hit it
kick it
dr belisse
lee sciatico here we go here we go
danny brown here we go here we go
are you [ __ ] kidding me or what
this is with black people with black
people right here huh
what
are you [ __ ] kidding me or what this
is too much i can't even listen to the
whole song i want to go out there and
stab some [ __ ]
democrats or republicans or [ __ ]
whatever the [ __ ] they are what's going
on dr police great to have you back
my little jewish brother i think james
brown could have used dr belisse help
him relax a little bit [ __ ] yeah james
brown had a lot of problems and [ __ ]
like that
there he is my lehigh brother
bad [ __ ] and look at you with
the cindy crawford you like it thank you
stop i did my hair yeah you look
beautiful
what's going on
i'm kind of a little international right
now are you ready i'll tell you yeah
going to australia
london
sweden i am big in sweden believe it or
not and all this to teach people how to
be how to breathe crazy right i'm the
first one that thinks it's kind of
interesting i wake up i can't believe it
this is what i do
yeah you helped me dramatically i will
talk about the steps i took and
i did like a ji kundo effect to your
book
i took your book but i played the annie
with it yeah and i said i told you i
used boss rooting his breather perfect
and then i went to
hypnosis to take the fear away
and i figured out that the more and more
and more i just went to jiu jitsu i
wouldn't think about it no more
you know if i'm out of oxygen you tap
that's it
and that saved me a lot so i want to
thank you for giving me a book
you took it and then you flew with it
you know you got i teach basics right i
teach basics and then you took it and
you changed it you made it up your own
you did your good stuff there was only
one thing that i had an argument with
not really an argument
was that when i did it i did it with the
intention
i think when you wrote the book you said
you could do it in 14 days it took me a
little longer
because and i worked at it yeah because
i at first i did it for like 17 days
and i saw a little um
more i had more ability instead of
holding my breath for 23 seconds i was
holding for 28. nice there were things
like that that were happening
but i still had to eliminate that fear
that fear was always [ __ ] there yeah
when i was a kid i could hold my breath
forever
but with the sleep apnea it dug into
places in my mind so yeah
she was like a hypnotherapist she
hypnotized me and she gave me a dvd
to take home and bring with me and i
gotta tell you something it helped okay
but it helped along with your breathing
exercises
boss rooting thing your exercises
weights to it
sometimes you do push-ups for three
months yeah you do
everybody will tell you that if you do
pull-ups push-ups sit-ups yeah and
squats you're good yeah that's it your
body will he more if you had
the things will release in your body you
know you do that for a year if you're in
prison like if you're in prison for 10
years you do everything you do push-ups
and you learn to like them you never say
it
oh yeah you learn to like them because
you know it's 35 minutes of your day
yeah it's 35 [ __ ] minutes of your day
you will do it every [ __ ] day
in that little room you will do a
thousand push-ups i love that lock-up
stuff they were doing stuff like they
were filling their their boxes with like
coffee yeah
like we had when i was locked up we had
a weight set but it was only a weight
set that went up to 180 pounds or
something
but these guys made a lap machine they
made
pull-up bars you know
so
but thank you that's what i want thank
you for for loving it and taking it
where it which went for you and i've
given the book away i've gotten it back
to some people in jiu jitsu and they've
made notes
so there's a lot of great interesting
stuff there if you're having problems
breathing
if you're rolling and you don't know
what's going on and it's just something
that you're absolutely right uh you're
born with the natural ability to breathe
and somewhere along the line your
central nervous system yeah you know uh
messes it up and you catch yourself in
bad habits and bad habits are hard to
break it's like smoking a cigarette or
excessive masturbation or
you know something like that that's a
long time to stop ice cream every day
it you have to get off it you have to
change your mind's way of thinking now i
know at night
i still have the same pattern of
breathing yeah i start off breathing out
of my nose and sleep apnea mask okay but
i know i'm breathing out of my [ __ ]
mouth you try to tape
tape over my mouth and just breathe out
of my nose
i know it sounds silly and but super
simple but guess what someone's going to
make a gadget that's a 10 gadget that
just keeps your lips together why not
just use tape
that's true too what about those
mouthpieces
you know they can work that's why a lot
of guys who roll who wear mouth guards
they will always breathe through their
nose because they've been trained you
know well you have those mouthpieces
that have holes in them yeah if they're
on amazon for like 20 bucks yeah if you
want to do that i got to get a [ __ ]
mouthpiece somebody clocked me in the
eye the other day look i still got a
black guy it was tremendous it felt
great how would a mouthpiece help with
the eye huh
because he lost me
if he would have needed his tooth that
would have been a vampire without a fang
right now you know what i'm saying
i'm just [ __ ] sad
i'm a vampire without a fan a vampire
without a fang is it's like a [ __ ]
without an [ __ ] oh no they gotta work
you know what i'm saying
you have a great uh
ted talk or tedx talk i got a little
next talk yeah it was
and like the one of the more interesting
things and you were just talking about
it with the way that you breathe up and
down oh jesus christ
this kid you know why you know why
because he eats hummus
he's got i tell you he's got a stinky
neck what the [ __ ] is that he's got bugs
all over him constantly i can't even
kill that constantly he's got bugs on
him and [ __ ] there's a bee right now or
something
on the thing
last week he had a bee that came in here
that's like a that's like a roach
i think it's a roach why do you think
it's going to you because that sweetness
of that [ __ ] war juice you drink that
hummus
comes out of your [ __ ] boys am i like
i can't wait to go on vacation with you
by a million mosquitos and everybody
else don't get touched i was i shouldn't
have even pointed it out but it was
coming my way [ __ ] from the hummus and
the tracks all those scorpios
yes it does that was a [ __ ] scorpion
there's not even scorpions in southern
california and you got a [ __ ]
scorpion on your [ __ ] table like a
spider scorpion you don't say it by me
you don't see it by dr belise you know
why because it's that combination of
that [ __ ] korean [ __ ] [ __ ]
mixed with that [ __ ] fungus for
hummus stuff hummus looks like the stuff
i squeeze out of the [ __ ] pimples on
my neck that's what this is someone's
eating hummus right now right now yeah
yeah [ __ ] that's what they get on a
chip that's that pimple juice on a
[ __ ] chip oh stop it
a bunch of isis are squeezing pimples in
your hummus right now that's why trader
joe's always has a recall where did that
even come from i think it just appeared
it's the truth because that's what comes
out of you if they smell you a mile away
with that hummus that's how we get
that's how we bombard those people in
[ __ ] tehran and [ __ ] where the [ __ ]
countries are they have like a hummus
seeking missiles yeah they had like a
hummus smell but warmth from [ __ ]
houses
that's the problem i [ __ ] hate that
[ __ ] it's like a podcast like no other
if i was trump i would ban hummus and
really make these [ __ ] people go
crazy no travel ban
just bad [ __ ] hummus thank god you're
not his his food advice oh that'd be the
first thing i'd done i'm gonna start
writing him letters tomorrow you want to
get rid of these [ __ ] people
[ __ ] ban hummus all these
knuckleheads
i'm not talking about just people from
the states that are on the ban list i'm
talking to wrestling about you [ __ ]
gentiles and they're eating hummus jesus
died on the cross so you wouldn't have
to eat hummus and here you are eating
[ __ ] hummus jesus got stabbed 90
times beat up for 12 hours so we didn't
have to subdue ourselves to eat [ __ ]
hummus
jesus took it in the [ __ ] heart and
sailed away
because he couldn't believe after he
took the beat he took
and he died you [ __ ] are still
eating hummus what were those people
wearing sandals all of them eating
hummus having a good [ __ ] time which
i gotta stop smoking is hummus bad is it
almost bad for you dr balisa that's what
the world needs to know you know hummus
is chickpeas so it depends how you feel
about chickpeas if you don't like
chickpeas you're not gonna like it when
i came from cuba
my mother married this dude named
juanito juan oriento and i loved him
that was his name because he had four
brothers in cuba and they would all kill
you
juanito carto viento's favorite dish was
gabon sofrito
so he would take those [ __ ] garbanzo
beans you [ __ ] gentiles eat just like
that out of a can you [ __ ] animals
and he would take those up and he would
fry those up
with chorizo real spanish chorizo from
spain with onions and green peppers
you have no [ __ ] idea
what i do right now i used to tell him
to go [ __ ] himself whenever he cooked
that i ate it for like a year but then
out of my hate for him i thought i
started [ __ ] blockading it like i put
like a [ __ ] embargo on it like i
wouldn't eat none of his meals no more
except he made um
that you had to look at him and call him
mister and i mean
this mother listen i hated them bro
i hated them but every time i went to
new york you bet your ass if i didn't
show up at this house with three pounds
of shrimp
and that dude was so happy to cook it
for me because he knew how much that
shrimp
and i eat it now sometimes yeah not the
same it's dead in new york it's not the
same and he put peas in it and i'd curse
him and it was still good
you're supposed to put peas on it not
over abundance it's like when you eat
the last seasoning of the peas the ones
on top of the beer you put the beer and
then the [ __ ] peas on top
let me tell you something that dude made
the garbanzo frito and for years i ate
those garbanzo beans because they were
[ __ ] delicious with the chorizo
and i stopped eating them and today
i would give a finger if he came back
from the dead like if he came back for
24 hours from the dead and came to my
house i'd have him cook [ __ ] chorizo
with the [ __ ] garbanzo beans but
that's the only [ __ ] god
just mash it up and then it's a cuban
hummus it'll be spicy
i don't eat that vegan [ __ ] i like
felipe
it has chorizo in it it's like the
opposite of vegan it's opposite of vegan
oh you got me thinking about raccoon
camarones my dad made some camaros
yellow rice oh yeah yeah the yellow rice
and peppers oh my god that shit's a
[ __ ] magnastic some of that cuban
food is really [ __ ] good it's
fantastic but in the words of rudy sarzo
you do that for a week and you get on
the scale and you [ __ ] cannot
believe the weight that you put on it's
like different calories than other food
it just it's exponential calories i
don't i can't you know i love listen
let's be honest
my favorite cuban dish of all time and
if anybody knew this you'd agree with me
it's beautiful that's the thin steak
that they beat up with a hammer
and they put these seasonings on it
white rice and black beans with raw
onions on the black beans and rice
for that i can eat that every night let
me tell you something if i lift weights
five sets of six behind the next squats
i would get ginormous eating that what
that food the steak with the white rice
and the black beans
the cuban food makes you lift if you
lift with cuban food yeah oh
oh garbanzo what's that thing they make
that stuff is pure protein that stuff
gets your dick
but i went to the hospital when i was 15
i had a lung infection i was spitting
blood and i had a uh
something in my lung from paraquat
paraquad
but when i got out my mom felt it was
part of my diet
because at that point i was cooking for
myself and i was eating the same [ __ ]
every night i was eating [ __ ]
steakhum
with white rice with a white bread
listen dawg
i'm the only cuban that could eat i
could win the [ __ ] record for eating
wonder breads do you understand me i
love wonder bread okay but flies okay i
love white rice too with steakhouse no
no no no no no no that's disgusting okay
that's right
i would take those all right the french
fries oh nice yeah
you put those in the oven a bunch of
those you put heavy salt and pepper with
some ketchup
with a [ __ ] fried steak and with
american cheese and some onions on white
bread
was the white bread bimbo remember that
way no i'm only i'm a i'm a [ __ ]
bread type of [ __ ] i think it's
closed now isn't it no i still get the
wheat white and i got the wheat wheat
wonder bread has wheat yeah well it
doesn't even and they have wheat that's
white
yeah that's what i thought it was they
have wheat that's white bread and then
they have a wheat wheat bread
and for eat breakfast i skip all that
[ __ ] yeah i throw away bread every week
i feed the pigeons and [ __ ] because i
just want it at the house
so i like the 21 grain
multigrain bread for breakfast with an
egg that's good [ __ ] yeah not a lot of
carbs good for you
you change your breakfast every time i
see you your breakfast has changed you
change it around a little bit i avoid i
eliminate the bacon now yeah
i eliminate the bacon
so that some days i have two eggs with
two pieces of toast with butter bam
or two pieces of white bread with fruit
and uh scrambled eggs
that's my breakfast
i'm getting between all this food talk
i'm hungry 10 o'clock a protein shake
i'm beyond
pretty good protein shake and then lunch
something small whatever my wife gives
me i try to take
my appetite shrunk the last couple weeks
i wanted you know i'm getting older you
don't want this much meat on you or when
you're late 50s and [ __ ] so little by
little not you i'm talking about me
so now you're training more people you
still like sometimes we speak and i get
off the phone
and i'm really in shock
of the type of people you train like
[ __ ] israeli [ __ ]
god guys
you taught them how to breathe these
guys are supposed to be
the best of the best
and they don't know how to breathe
nobody's teaching listen
few jiu jitsu people except for nick
gregorius bjj brotherhood
have a special tape
just for breathing but you could walk
into any jujitsu school and they don't
dictate a day or two to jiu jitsu
breathing the reason why i go to drill
class
is because drill class will teach me the
movements i need and when to breathe
so i could think about it number one two
three right here on breathing i'm not
breathing that's how much i had to take
it so i could learn how to breathe but
the breathing was not the only thing dr
bliss it was that [ __ ] fear
yeah that every time i grasped for air
and i didn't get it yeah the world was
ending well think about it every night
you went through that with the sleep
apnea so it was deep
that was deep
but if you get you know if you get told
to use a sleep mask the cpap use it
there's a lot of people that don't want
to
use it look at this chick
she died from sleep apnea
that's the truth you know why because
number one when you're on a plane the
air is thin already
you want to [ __ ] around with drugs on a
plane
whether it's coke or [ __ ] and i did
it for years i did blow and flew and
drank cocktails up in the air
but you got to realize something at 60
years old
she had heroin cocaine
the chicken just died star wars carry
fish yeah 16. okay then she got in the
plane and fell asleep
okay when you get on a [ __ ] plane if
you gotta sleep apnea let me tell you
something don't [ __ ] fall asleep i
got thrown off a plane one time in
newark
because i fell asleep before the plane
took off
in those days those chairs once i set
back i would fall asleep my neck went
back and i started going
and they [ __ ] woke me up and said
you're getting off the plane though you
scared the [ __ ] out of everybody
you're like a [ __ ] halloween mask
you're scared i was 400 pounds
i remember one time i was in dallas
and i was doing a tour
and we had to get up saturday morning
this was like a sign this is lee this is
lee this is 2004
maybe
i had done mad tv maybe spider-man 2
and a couple other things and this
producer called me
this black promoter he wanted to call it
the latin knights of comedy
and you had a blow up a blow up tent
in the back that had like a castle to it
it was a joke every show we did he
always came to your room later on and
if he told you 800 it was 650 now
because he didn't sell enough tickets
one night i got a knock on the door from
the radio people he never paid the radio
people
and he ran it's on your seat now now
what's up
that's it you got to stop eating hummus
maybe dr melissa eats hummus no it's you
it's you with that hummus it's trying to
get back to me you're attracting roaches
and [ __ ] god damn it this is what i
didn't [ __ ] want you god damn it
you eat that [ __ ] pizza tonight i
didn't actually that pizza away goddamn
it oh you didn't you ate that no i
didn't i have the camera
you ate the pizza jesus christ maybe
it's the
[ __ ] weed that falls on the floor
there just don't come to weak trust me
it's that [ __ ] hummus that comes out
of your pores
you smell like a [ __ ] sweet cake for
these [ __ ] things with that eating
that [ __ ]
last week a bee came in and went right
to him
there was a spider on him that landed on
him about a month ago are you seriously
why do you think all these things happen
i don't know
maybe because that thing comes out of
your [ __ ] neck that pumice smell
like i told it smell his neck it smells
like hummus and [ __ ]
i wish i moved to israel right now don't
blame the israelis no i'm saying i move
there right now if my humble my next
month like homeless
i'm a nice little idf girl
so when you go to israel and you teach
the problem a guy guy like a whatever he
was he was like a high art yeah yeah he
was a head of the israeli cro uh
american israeli and what were his
problems like what's not to do to
discuss something no no
no it's fine he actually you know gave
me an endorsement and was really into it
but he was breathing inhale he went up
and exhale he collapsed which is what
most people do they go inhale and they
try to like get taller and puff up their
chest and then they exhale they collapse
and think about it if you just collapse
when you exhale you're not squealing
you're not getting uh carbon dioxide out
so you need to completely change the way
the framework that you breathe and
breathe the way you did when you were a
little kid when you were a little kid
you were fine that's so when people say
oh you know breathing is natural yeah
till you're five and then you screw it
up
and then so you have to go back and
think like okay how does my diaphragm
work it works so that you inhale and you
expand your body and then the exhale
should be your body narrows it shouldn't
be up and down you shouldn't why are you
using your shoulders to breathe you got
a diaphragm that's like a huge muscle in
the middle of your body that's supposed
to make you breathe not your shoulders
doesn't make any sense but we screw it
up and we breathe just enough to live
but not really to to get all the oxygen
we need to use our diaphragm so that we
don't have back pain so we don't have
digestive problems it's all part of it
it's all part of it i can tell how much
breathing has changed my life working on
it has changed my colors better yeah
your exhale is great yeah everything you
know now when i finish class and i do a
litmus test
it's always at that [ __ ] light green
it's very nice perfect yeah you know it
used to be black
that it was crazy
he would like so it's a ph strip that
looks the acidity inside your body and
joey would lick this and i couldn't
believe the thing would go from yellow
to black
black there's nothing but thc smoke in
me
and i would tell people that when she
put needles in me and acupuncture or cut
me
dr amy doesn't get high
she got no reason i got a relationship
with dr amy of 10 or 11 years
dr amy got no reason a lot of me dr amy
would tell me
how much weed i was smoking
wow by me going to acupuncture and her
cupping me
she would say joey you've been hitting
it hard
i go how do you know she goes [ __ ]
look at these cups i can feel the heat
coming off your body
you smell it every time i hit you with a
[ __ ] needle you know it's like
[ __ ] invisible smoke
comes out of you you know there's times
i work out dr police and as i'm taking
my shirt off
not even by the bottom by my ass if you
have a shirt and the back of it smells
funny that means your [ __ ] smells you
gotta do things you gotta get tushy.com
but like when my back in the middle of
my back always has a weird odor for it
for years from detoxing god knows what
comes out of your body kidneys are down
there too we found this shirt one time
when we moved up here nine years ago we
found a shirt
of mine that was hidden
that was when i weighed 418 pounds it
was one of my favorite shirts
it was a white
6x
shirt that i bought in texas and shrunk
it to fit me at that time i was like a
five and a half x
maybe a 5x
how do you shrunk it half a size and dr
melissa it was amazing to see
that we looked at it me and my wife
pulled it out she goes do you want this
shirt and we both looked at it
and you could see what i was doing to my
life at that time wow with that shirt
every other shirt from that time
my wife bleaches [ __ ] like i like my
[ __ ] clean you know like i like my [ __ ]
clean my wife knows in my house don't be
skimpy on the soap who gives a [ __ ] soap
is what four dollars buy soap add salt
put vinegar in with the geese to kill
the smoke my feet with that fungi
toenail put two cups of vinegar with
those and add those to my underwear too
cause god knows what comes out of my
[ __ ] at night you know you gotta add
two cups of vinegar i never even thought
your laundry routine oh must be crazy
yeah i got a [ __ ] heavy duty but i
looked at this shirt
and this was a really sad time in my
life because i was doing blow
i was not drinking water
forget about breathing right i didn't
even know you had to breathe
and i was doing blow and smoking
cigarettes
first of all you had to see the armpits
it looked like a coffee filter i'm
embarrassed to tell you guys
the armpits look like that's what was
coming out of me in those days it was
pure black and not even when you were
working out i was not working out those
days the only time i sweat was when i
did cocaine
there was no working out i was 418 lee
the only time i sweat was when i did an
8-ball and
and couldn't get my dick on i'd be
pounding like a monkey for that sentence
the only time i swear yeah was when i
did blow everything the only i was like
a recycling blow machine
i would snort blow and blow would go out
and it'd be fine it was [ __ ]
embarrassingly i'm embarrassed to tell
you this right now but it's a reality
but if you saw that shirt you would we
both looked at it folded and threw in
the garbage like
that life is dead were there like
cigarette holes in it no no no no no no
no just the armpit just the if you
looked at the armpits and it started
here like it was yellow and then the
more you went closer to the armpit
it was like breath let's face it there
your lymph is glenn there that's like
that's an important place in your body
between the nicotine and the cocaine and
the
eating 20 eggs and butter and god knows
what else
you know that's what happens to your
body man i wonder how long would don't
not to be morose but how much longer you
would have lasted on that road like what
is was it going to be a week was it
going to be 46 i would have died if i
was two years away from dying from the
blow
and how i knew this was i was starting
to get pain on my spinal cord
i was stunned at night once i'd do like
a gram of coke once after that
i would get sharp pains in my spinal
cord that would be like
somebody zapping me with those guns oh
yeah
so i knew something was going on i
didn't know what once i stopped doing
cocaine yeah i never got it again you
got to imagine that when you do coke
your blood pressure rises oh yeah
so in those days i was walking around
180 over one [ __ ] 60. at 4 18 i was
walking around i would go to the doctor
and they wouldn't let me leave to my
blood sometimes i have to sit there for
45 minutes
until my blood pressure would go under
140. they would give me like medication
extra medication
so it was a disaster so i would i think
i had maybe 18 months
before she would have found me on the
floor i would have had a heart attack
from the blow or something or stroke
i was going to get a warning sign god
had already started
painting the warning signs and it would
be weird i'd be on the computer and all
of a sudden my spine close to my neck
would feel like i was getting [ __ ]
stabbed in the [ __ ] spine so i was
like
if i keep doing this
you know it you know how much longer you
have if you keep going the way you are
yeah you know you can ask people that
and they know
they absolutely know i was telling lee
i've been watching the 600 pound man
because it's very interesting to me
in a funny way but also in a serious way
like
at one point
as a human being you go i gotta do
something about myself for me it was
418 pounds
and not being able to walk
three minutes on the
treadmill on like 1.5 like i just came
the guy stopped it he goes
you're in a pickle
you have to quit smoking and you have to
walk on your own there's nothing i can
do for you right now you can't bend
and i still had flexibility i could
still bend and touch my toes yeah you
were crazy
it was like if i bent over
i would
pick my head up and the world would spin
because there was no oxygen it was just
getting cut off i wonder what your
litmus test would have been then you'd
been off the charts it was terrible i
was always pre-diabetic then i was
always on the
he would always go
you come in here one more time like this
i'm gonna have to put you on medication
it was scary it was really [ __ ] scary
i had a guy come in to see me years ago
um as a therapist years ago like 10
years ago and he said you know you want
to talk about this and the other
and i said well we need to talk about
your weight because he was a very big
guy and i had a scared feeling like i
can tell things about people depending
on how i feel and i looked at him and i
felt scared for him and i said we got to
talk about your weight first you know we
can talk about the other things you know
what happened today so and so forth
let's talk about your weight but i
really like i was really firm i was
probably too firm
and i said we have to because you're on
the brink i can feel it like i know it
it to me i would be negligent it would
be unethical for me to let you go and
not ask you what's going on with your
body what's going on with your soul as
far as your weight and he didn't like
that he got like upset he thought he was
we all do yeah you're going into our
personal space as a fat dude
you know rogan was my agitator he take
me out to dinner and then while i'm
eating the steak he's like joey look at
how you eat you [ __ ] what'd you bring me
he gave a [ __ ] about me take me to a
[ __ ] salad house
you bring me in here the smallest steak
is a 16 ounce border house and then you
want to tell me when i'm biting into it
how [ __ ] fat i'm getting it and it
bothered me but
when you get to that heavy that's why
that show interests me because at one
point do you know
at one point you go wait a second i'm
not [ __ ] walking somebody like at
that point my wife was tying my
shoelaces
like when i did the longest yard there
was a point where she gonna help me get
dressed well didn't you know because i
mean
thank god i never got i got to 3 15
which is huge for me but i was still
able to walk and stuff
but
i knew like i would still get the food
but i'd be as soon as the food was gone
i'd feel bad like you know how big you
are i don't think i knew exactly how big
i was like that picture with us in cleo
is the biggest i ever was and it still
blows my mind but i knew i think don't
didn't you know a little bit or not
really
you know but you get to a point where
you just don't care you don't care
number one
and you want to test fate you want to
test
you want to test faith you want to test
science
you want to test out listen i'm still
not where i should be and i'm still not
where i want to be
but i got to tell you something if you
look at diets from 10 years ago to now
i'll blow your [ __ ] mind out the
water i would blow your mind what i used
to eat now
what i watch when i go to a restaurant i
eliminate the bread i eat this when i'm
on the road what i eat for breakfast
you know when i'm on the road i eat two
eggs the wheat toast a cup of oatmeal
and that's it
and that's it and that's why i lose
weight on the road people go i lose
weight on the road i know how to lose
weight on the road i gain weight on the
road the big thing with me is sugar yeah
people say if you have sugar in your
blood you cannot lose weight
for me sugar listen you're gonna eat
tomato sauce that's got everyday sugar
but i don't own a desserts
and i don't drink soft drinks
those two
are the killer calories and if i do get
a dessert it's a dessert for bring three
spoons
why should we have three desserts
that's gonna deserve to get three spoons
and get a cup of coffee and get some
water yep you know i go to a restaurant
i go to specific restaurants sometimes
because i have a great salad
i look forward more to the salad than
the meal
because now you know when i go to
let's just throw it out there like years
ago i'd go to morton's with joe or
something
or eddie and i would get the clam
chowder
[ __ ] the salad
i'd get like something heavy for like
fried shrimp
the clam chowder the bread wouldn't stop
with the butter by the [ __ ]
knife full yeah warm bread warmer too
right warm bread mortons or something i
would get the steak the mashed potatoes
i'd eat half of joe's
sides i'd eat half of eddie's sides and
then [ __ ] dessert for six let's get an
individual dessert and whoever didn't
want it like harry kazari skinny i would
eat his
that's what i ran at now if i go to a
restaurant i eat the steak i cut it in
half
if it's a 12 ounce i cut it in half and
i take the other half home you're
motivated because a steak at night is
the big [ __ ] thing for an agitator to
get a heart attack you want to get a
state you want to eat a big lobster tail
or a big meal don't eat it at night my
big meal now is at lunchtime good good
you know if i'm gonna eat a big meal
like today my wife made
24 ounces of [ __ ] halibut grilled so
i ate like 12 ounces of halibut with a
corn on the cup
i ate a ton of protein and i'm in a
protein shake yeah so i'm trying it's
not like i'm still eating ring things
yeah i love those
yodels
you know when i grew up in new york i
could eat a yodel every [ __ ] day
but then i went back and about four
years ago in a yoda it wasn't that good
it wasn't worth the calories
it's not worth the calories not with the
calories i'll take you to yum yum donuts
at night oh and those little mexican
donut makers without no papers
they make a donut that you have to think
let me tell you something if ice goes
into yum yum donuts and they go let me
get out yeah it'll be up against the
wall
all the mexican dude has to look at that
fat little white cop and go taste one of
those donuts do you really want to send
me back
even the [ __ ] cop would go you know
what let them stay just saying they ran
out good luck to you we love you we're
going to come in every night for donuts
by the way it's good that's how good yum
yum and if you got time in the daytime
least favorite is on magnolia
they got a blueberry doughnut that'll
make your [ __ ] shoot fireworks i've
always wanted that
but if you go to buffalo i think the
best donut i ever had was in buffalo new
york really yeah that's the best donut
i've ever had that and the lobster tails
at in richfield park new jersey
are the only things that i go off to die
for
when i lived on the lower east side
manhattan now i'm on the west side i
lived by a place called the donut plant
that was i live can you imagine living
here what is that to the donut plan it's
horrible
you could you could put a starter tap
when you got a tab with a donut place
yeah it's not going to end well for you
no have you tried a corona
i have not oh they live i don't want to
like anything else me neither yeah
that's why i never tried ecstasy like
when xyz was big i was like i got the
problems
what i'm saying i want to do
accidentally no no i don't i got the
problem
i want to do ecstasy and mdma and
[ __ ]
you know no no no the same way i don't
like trying nothing new
i like fish you know i eat a lot of fish
i eat as much fish as i can
the steak you're careful you're careful
with the mercury and all that right yeah
what are you gonna do
all right listen if you eat steak it's
got steroids if you eat chicken it's got
steroids if you eat lamb
it's got everything you eat is [ __ ]
bad for you so what are you going to
tell you
and then there's hummus it's a bad
situation what are you doing next where
are you headed
so
i'm teaching i'm teaching a lot of
people's right now so just came from san
francisco did what's called the master
class there and took all my top students
and worked on them there i had firemen
uh had yoga instructors i want to bring
you to an inversion yoga class you and
your wife if she wants to come where is
it yeah at culver city
how's that you're in no danger
culver city is like [ __ ]
new jersey
i got the baby up here the problem with
me is i don't like strain unless she's
local
if she's got to go somewhere then i stay
local
we'll come to you if i go to jiu jitsu
if i go to jiu jitsu
i don't bring my phone into jiu jitsu
because i know my wife is lurking north
so you follow me i'm one of those dudes
you don't cross the tent i don't cross
the tent though that holder said he's a
[ __ ] dog yeah unless you go on
like 11 o'clock in the [ __ ] morning
or something
and what i'm saying like what the [ __ ]
that's like new york not crossing east
side west side nobody wants to go east
side west side near somebody tells me
now i'm on the upper west to go to the
lower east side i'm not doing it
how long does it take is it crazy it's
not i mean the traffic here is just you
know you don't do the subway what do you
think the traffic is worse here in new
york at this point in your life right
now
here because there's more space the
traffic in new york is not that bad if
you avoid two or three streets at
specific times you're fine and the
subway is so good
the subway is so good you know it
doesn't even matter how much we tell you
something man you gotta have balls just
every time you go on this side well i
love this you gotta go on the subway
like you're 50 it could be your last day
every time you go on one of those new
york subways it could be your last day
look how different it was the subway
cars in the 70s though you remember
those crazy looking cars full of
graffiti they were disgusting but that
was the art that was the
flare that new york had
when you got on the train in the 70s
it was hilarious
at 8 in the morning you got on the train
and you were having a bad day
you got off that train going you know
what man
my life ain't that bad after all because
either you had the heroin people on the
train withdrew the fall
league
they used to be on the bus too lee
the number one bus from north from
jersey city north bergen we'd get on
there as kids and they'd be a heroin guy
and the first time those seats emptied
next to him we jump in and we start
throwing spitballs out of his [ __ ] so he
woke up you have no idea how much heroin
people entertainment they are because
when they wake up they try to look at
you like they're not on heroin and they
don't know that
they think that they got you fooled
but they'll try to like be all sharp and
while they're doing this while they're
scratching their face they'll just fall
asleep again
then they'll [ __ ] wake up and [ __ ]
and like
make believe like what time do you have
what
can i borrow your daily news like you're
really going to [ __ ] read it and why
are you torturing because why not you're
12. you're 13. you got a torture or you
had to pee in the 90s
early 90s when i went back to new york
you had the people you got on the train
and right before the train closed one
skinny black dude got out
and once the train took off you go can i
have your attention ladies and gentlemen
can i have your attention ladies and
gentlemen
my name is leo and i got aids not only
do i have aids i have sickle cell anemia
i got diabetes
i got the flu i got a headache i got a
toothache i'm missing a finger i'm a
veteran of vietnam i'm missing a foot i
got agent orange
i got syphilis i got a hernia pms i got
pms i got diabetes and all i'm looking
for is for a little donation brother i'm
gonna pass the hat around
and that was and then while the hat was
going around lee he busted out into song
about all of his elements
what song would that be like some song
about happiness
yeah sunday sunday sunday
sunday it's gonna be a sunny day because
the people on the train are gonna make
my son a day and he would sing and
people would be going oh no
and he'd get like a dollar fifty and
they go [ __ ] you [ __ ]
and he jump over to the other train
though
it was right there you walk off that
train going you know what
these three bucks in my pocket they
don't feel that bad now i don't feel
that bad about having three dollars
no
i guess not now you're going to go to
the train
home we do have cops on every platform
which helps
i'm just so paranoid of all that [ __ ]
when i'm in an airport now i'm [ __ ]
scared that that i don't like standing
in the front of [ __ ] airports no more
like usually you get to an airport
you're three hours ahead of the game you
check in they take your big luggage
you sit there you go i can go inside the
airport it's a sunny day you know you
used to stand outside over at lax now
after three minutes you'll leave because
there's a guy that walks by you with a
[ __ ] machine gun
the size of [ __ ] rambo in 1985. and
once you actually see that machine gun
five feet from you it does something to
your heart dog it dampens it it's not a
[ __ ] tv show this is real life the
other night i went out i checked in
early last thursday when i went to
canada
uh [ __ ] whatever kennedy airport i
got the lax in 10 minutes there was no
traffic at 1 30. i checked my luggage i
went outside i was outside five [ __ ]
minutes and two guys walk in front of me
with [ __ ] guns
that could kill a [ __ ] or an ant but
when you want to be near them if the
stuff is going off like not at all i
don't want to be that close to a [ __ ]
weapon going off ever in my life do i
want to be near them i don't want them
at the [ __ ] airport they should not
be there why because
we shouldn't be in this predicament lee
that's why
yeah but people are [ __ ] bringing
they just brought a gun into lax like a
year or two ago
that's that [ __ ] weird guy with a
rifle
you know you're not getting my point
okay i'm sorry when i was a kid right
i'd go to the airport and light my balls
on fire in the front and i could feel
safe
that a car wasn't going to come running
through and go and then killing 16
people standing there waiting for a
platform to stand on that platform no
more doug i watch everything now because
you have to
you have to you have to watch everything
so but to see it's like when have you
ever hugged somebody when you go to hug
them they got a piece no
have you ever done that when you're
going to hug them they have a piece it's
a lot different it's like touching
somebody's [ __ ] soul your whole body
gets goose hairs even if you love the
person
you love the person when you hug
somebody let's say if they're just in
new york and you bump into something
they got a
piece and i have friends that would hug
and then have illegal pieces on their
back
my body would shake yeah i can't even oh
my god you just i don't need that in my
life you don't know what that's likely
to hug somebody and they got a piece on
them i don't even think my brain would
go to them and they got two other dudes
with pieces on them
but you grew up with them so you got to
stop and talk to them and hug them and
they want to buy you a drink and talk to
you about the weather but the whole time
you're going this guy's got a [ __ ]
piece on him i know for a fact he ain't
a [ __ ] cop why are they crying and
they just even though
sometimes
when i see bobby i know he's a cop when
i hug him
my hand [ __ ] freezes
because he's got a piece on him and your
mind goes right to why is he have a
piece on him and what does this mean for
me
i don't i don't even think i would even
consider it was a gun
unless i saw it i'd be like what does he
have in his back pocket
i like
i don't even think it would come into my
brain if it wasn't a comp like are those
people like criminals or are they just
people the guys the first guys you know
the guys i'm talking about yeah
are they criminals yeah who knows i
don't know the definition right
they bought me a drink they gave me a
hug you need to hug more people lee i
think that's what it means is lean needs
to hug more people so that you have more
hugging experiences i have a lot of i'm
a great hugger that's the only thing
that being chubby is good for but
no i
i yeah i don't know i'm trying to think
if i've ever
i don't think so
your dad didn't have a gun huh no
you're not dealt okay so oh yeah he i
mean he dealt in cash but we lived in
the suburbs of the suburbs we had we had
a huge security we had a security system
in our house
when i was growing up but uh
yeah guns and guns are always tough
we've talked about it before no guns
were a tough one but yeah now i mean how
could he not now i'm i'm
yeah i think everyone has to get one now
almost it seems like it
you never [ __ ] know unless you look
like dr belisse with the little shorts
with the pink shirt holding some heat
and [ __ ] do you i mean
are you still doing a lot of seminars dr
released the weekend ones
not as much really not as much because
i'm tr so i'm traveling and just
teaching the classes so i'm not doing as
many workshops so when you travel like
all right so you're going to where
you're going where's the first one so uh
so back to san francisco okay so
you know what i do workshops for
warriors i'm still doing work okay
because i love that class that class
right
and people leave then they hit you back
oh my gosh they've changed they're
fantastic yeah absolutely um
so we yeah so the warriors classes i
still do if a gym asks me to do a
warriors class i do it
um do i do any regular classes not as
much because i just really i can you
know there's so many hours in a day and
you have so much energy so i'm like i
can do a teacher's workshop i can do a
training but that's going to be the
whole trip
you know it's so funny how i just got a
thought when i was talking to you
what your book did was really um
it tightened my game
that's what
when a system really supposed to work
the second one i tell people a thousand
times when i went to joe namath football
camp first thing you did when you went
to joe namath football camp was you sat
down
you said hello to joe
you stretched and you went and he timed
your 440. he timed your 40.
and what they did was every morning
before anything at 7 30 to 8
they would do a running class and he
would re-teach you how to run
he would re-teach you how to run from
scratch how to walk take the paces
what's the knee where's the back
supposed to be where's your throat
supposed to be what are your arms
supposed to be doing doing the run it
was very basic
and he'd make you practice it 10 times
and that was it you wouldn't eat
breakfast
10 times on tuesday you want to make
breakfast wednesday the same thursday
the same on friday he put you on the
line and he said ready to run the 40 and
you ran to 40 and boom your speed
improved by [ __ ] unbelievable you sit
there and you go joe you're a genius i'm
just saying one of the coaches there
would do it not joe namath
but all he did was re-teach you the
mechanics
and that's what you did with my
breathing and so your nose breathe if
[ __ ] gets hairy
take short breaths so it slows down your
heart you know you taught me how to
you taught me how to do something that i
did for blood pressure i went down there
they were [ __ ] in shock i was 140
over 120 or 140 over 80. they were in
shock beautiful yeah they were in shock
but that's what the breathing has done
you know
a lot of my thing was not not breathing
like that story i was telling you ever
get caught in dallas like no
yeah we got caught at dallas airport oh
yeah around and
you have no idea lee what happened your
flight's delayed
and you don't have an hour
you know what happens
and one day i landed in one of those
[ __ ] toys that i was doing with that
black dude
and we had to go from like mississippi
to alabama or something crazy and we had
to fly something happened
we had to go through dallas airport
and brother we had a run for like six
minutes i hadn't run six minutes
since 19 [ __ ] 93
and now i'm running at 2003
at 400 [ __ ] pounds for that airport
and i'll never forget sitting there and
i had to i think i'll tell you dr malize
for a half hour i really thought i was
gonna die in that plane because i
couldn't fit in the chair
so i couldn't breathe properly yeah and
i couldn't get up to get my lungs oh my
god
like i just feel this bone here now
for 10 years i never felt this bone when
i lose the weight and i felt that bone i
went to the doctor
and i said touch that i got cancer and
he goes what are you talking about
that's your chest bone
i go i've never had this before
so that's how much
fat i had on my chest that i couldn't
even feel so even with all that my lungs
were not really breathing that's why my
skin color
was horrific
because there wasn't enough oxygen going
into me if i would have done the litmus
test in those days it would have just
disintegrated
[Laughter]
hey can you tell that when you read
right when you take a good breath you
make it to the end of your sentence like
you're you have longer sentences you can
go for a longer amount of time when you
take a good breath when you're like
inhale exhale inhale and then go
can you tell
it's getting better i think even with
stand up yeah
is the true test now that i can catch
myself breathing through my nose i've
never really seen you be out of breath
on stage because i've been breathing out
of my nose on stage lately okay i added
that i'm not breathing out of my mouth
no more and talking out of my mouth at
the same time
so i'm taking a short little breath what
do you think happens when you're on
stage
and the lights hit you
and your testosterone levels [ __ ]
rise and the animals hit you and your
adrenaline rise and the edibles hit you
you got [ __ ] four winds coming
together
so the only way to get yourself out of
that is to breathe out of your [ __ ]
nose
take short breaths say short words
instead
and just focus and play them for four
minutes they don't know you
like you guys doing all right yeah
good
you knew you're
see those old jew tricks there's a
little jew taught me that lisa
are you guys doing all right yeah you
guys doing all right great to be here
tonight
it was great getting him
i had some pierogies you know you could
just stick your finger up there for four
minutes until you get your composure
back
oh i got that done by the way what the
finger up the butthole i know which one
with the doctor yeah it was a doctor
you got to get that you got to get that
test he's 28 but that's good that he
tries it now what is it
leo you do it now you have to do it
until you're 40.
if your results came back negative oh
yeah he said it was fine but it was just
i never expected he was just he kept
telling me to relax
jump up the door how's he gonna stick a
finger up your ass if you're jumping up
for joy
you gotta bend over
the real way you got to do it is to lay
down on the table yeah i was hoping for
that you and you crinkle up like this
like a little angel with your legs up
and that's the easiest way to stick a
finger up your ass they put that crazy
glue
that [ __ ] fake [ __ ] and they [ __ ]
put on their finger he had me in like
the prison position and then he sure he
put it on he put the thing on then he
then like one movement he like lubed it
up and then put it in like and then he
fell for something oh riley fell for
like a little nerve or something yeah he
like i think it was checking then he
pulls down he
so i couldn't get a picture but you
should have seen the scene of the
paper towels and then the the uh crushed
bottle of lube left on the counter as i
was like getting dressed it was like the
most depressing thing
he said he told me to wipe myself it was
like it's terrible it's terrible and
then you wipe your ass and there's a
little bit of [ __ ] left over from that
morning mixed with that gel
it's like that little mix dude i didn't
eat all day like no other podcast i
didn't eat all day because i was worried
about that i didn't want to have [ __ ] on
it i was like i can't even it's like
when you come in somebody's ass but it
comes out a little brownish you know
what i'm saying when it comes out ten
minutes later
it's never happened to me
what's happened dr melissa
can i just um remind you yes and just
who's listening that by short i think
you mean that you s you breathe as
um
slowly as possible like fewer breaths in
a minute
so you don't pant because if you were
going
you'd get yourself
you know like i used years ago before i
went on stage i could dance yeah so i
would do a little dance and pick my leg
up if i do that now
i'll have a [ __ ] time i would have a
heart attack i would really have a heart
attack because can you do a split
he probably i could do a split i'm about
he probably can't inches away from doing
this but i just don't go for it because
what's the use of this you don't want to
brag at this age rip that [ __ ] muscle
it's a long recovery oh yeah no don't
lose muscle between your legs especially
there's one that my buddy ripped that's
only water ski is ripped
that they actually have to go and
there's a certain muscle in the leg
that only water skiers
rip i gotta look that up and a friend of
mine that played professional football
yeah and listen to the deal with this
[ __ ] muscle
that the percentages like it's a 40
chance that you'll rip the other one if
you work this one yeah so that's exactly
what happened he ripped that one his
rookie year did the rehab sat out
went back his second year and
during drills ripped the other one and
that was the end of his career that's
how quick it is
so right now i try not to uh water
skiing yeah definitely don't
i don't need to [ __ ] do high fly you
know i kick the bag still but i don't
need to do
kicks above my head no more i'm just
kicking to the body
during all those kicks and anytime i hit
the back
i'm really working on my breathing i'm
working on ways for the breathing to
help me then especially to take away
that panic that i had when i was out of
breath
that was a horrible feeling for a long
time terrible
and now i only go there maybe twice a
month and it goes away real fast
i can't go into something really fast
i'm 54 years old so i have to go into a
room and do a warm-up and do push-ups
and sit-ups and all the stretches
yeah and then i could do like light
weights or kettlebells and then i
increase it
but the more warm-up i have the better
workout i'll have
but it's the warm-up is all focused on
the breathing another guy you should
talk to really is alberto crane
aka
galazzi aka scott sonnet
they're the creators of you're going to
go to this uh yeah you're going to go to
the island academy in austin okay are
you oh yeah i'm teaching there i was
like i'll go there too yeah i'm teaching
there in the fall
big big workshop yeah that's a great
place they have a lot of place going in
there but scott
at one time but they used they sell a
lot of steel bats and all that that's
all
and they're really big into the breeding
that's why i love going to albertos
because alberto really incorporates it
with the jiu jitsu it's very interesting
i would love to meet the gift you
brought to the podcast listeners
was
phenomenal i got a thousand emails from
people that you sent books to and they
read the books and they really enjoyed
what you were doing you got people at
seminars that showed up you know
i love them when they come to seminars
what you have to offer is not a big sell
you know you actually know like lisa you
actually know when you have a problem
when something man right when you walk
up the stairs at work and you're you're
[ __ ] gassed okay
and you ride your bicycle there's
something not going on right there's
something that you talk to your bicycle
writing friends maybe you're maybe
you're recuperating less time than they
are
there's so many different variables that
people know what they're doing if they
ask around
that they all go have to go back to
breathing wow maybe my breathing's off
sorry about that my breathing is off my
allergies it's like i snorted 22 [ __ ]
g bows like a rebound
let me do some shout outs real quick
i know you got a boogie with stew
rob linked
jerk podcast highlights mark wilson
nerdy derby
tato el
trey insurance guy robert van kraken
will smith super hot 93
i love you [ __ ] with all my
heart look at this there's an imprint of
a red star
on my piece of paper
that's how strong that is don't forget
this thursday night
working out with uncle joey i got six
new topics i want to work out 10 bucks 8
30 you're out of there by 10. we giggle
leo be there he's the master of
ceremonies as usual and that's it then
the following week oh [ __ ]
vegas south point casino 7 30 show
you're out of there by nine o'clock you
could go to 10 o'clock joe rogan
excuse me and still jump up and down
with him and tony hinchcliffe that's the
type of [ __ ] i is
and i'm doing friday and saturday so
don't forget about me [ __ ] lickers
go ahead not paying me what were you
saying
he's spending money you were talking
about um
what was i saying i'm saying thank you
for having me is what i'm saying [ __ ]
i love you all the time yeah i think
this is the funnest this is the i mean
it's the funnest part
you walked in here you came in here with
something very interesting
that we should talk about okay can you
whip it out yeah we'll whip it out
oh that and not yet
get away a little while you want to see
it okay it's the proto it's what we can
do
it's the prototype i'm over here
thought something was going to happen
because i was saying to you show me that
thing and you're like
i actually was thinking yeah yeah
this is we're working on this together
in some way
this i think
is
very [ __ ] important
and you're talking from somebody who
didn't do it for cocaine reasons and for
sleep apnea reasons
and i got to tell you something
people have no idea how important it is
to sleep
and dog it took me 40 years
40 [ __ ] years i thought it was a
[ __ ] joke
i thought it was a [ __ ] joke
i thought it was a [ __ ] joke dr
belisse saw on top of not eating good
not exercising doing drugs
having sleep apnea high blood pressure
i was doing the one that sets all that
[ __ ] off
which is sleeping because if you don't
sleep you're more hungry
you're [ __ ] hungrier i mean your
blood pressure goes up and i can feel it
like your brain i mean it's [ __ ]
horribly
and people have no idea how important it
is and if you're a man and you're
choking or your girlfriend's telling you
you're snoring do me a favor dog
from the bottom of my heart
go down and get a sleep apnea test your
insurance will cover it because they
don't want to pay for the damage that's
going to happen later
i can't believe carrie fisher died from
that [ __ ]
that means she got high went on a plane
and her uh her heart
level went low
and then by not supplying oxygen she
went under because there's not enough
oxygen in this dog i took a nap
yesterday on jet blue it's no [ __ ]
picnic even with the mask
i plugged that [ __ ] mask in
it's no picnic on a plane you're still
up there
you're still up there dog
and the air is thin you're still up
there i woke up my [ __ ] band was wet
my head was wet thank god i brought a
hat in the bag because i'm prepared you
know what i'm saying
but sleep apnea is no [ __ ] joke man
and i didn't know it [ __ ] with women
too
i had no idea i thought it was the
number one killer
amongst men but i didn't know her [ __ ]
with women too
so even if you're just snoring that
could be that's the beginning of the
that's the beginning think about what
snoring is it's like flesh in the inside
of your body that's not letting the air
go in and out of your body okay yeah so
it's obstruction it's not just a snore
and can it go away when you lose weight
because i've
i've heard that when i gain when i lose
weight my snoring is
uh
not better i guess it's
false
when you get fat your neck gets big okay
yeah yeah okay like right now i'm
falling asleep on the couch in my house
for 45 minutes
i can fall asleep at the airport sitting
there for 15 minutes
when the plane takes off i can fall
asleep for the first 15 minutes that's
it as it's going up
and then once it gets to 30 000 feet
this apnea will wake me up
but i don't want to go there like you
don't want to go to that app near that
and once you start choking
that's when your brain that's when you
get a court because then your body
releases cortisol levels
and that's when your body goes to [ __ ]
we discuss the hump on your back
when i was 418 the other thing i forgot
to tell you guys was that i had a hump
on my back
did you know that dr belize the hump was
already starting to come out
once the hump starts coming out there's
no turning back
because when cortisol gets released
it [ __ ] coagulates right behind your
[ __ ]
right in the cross there right right
there in your lung cage right there
so you get that lump in your back that's
why you see those fat guys first you get
the lump on the neck and then you get
the [ __ ] skin in the head
and the fatness that means it's all
downhill it's just a matter of time
before it all collapses and what is
the what that's the one thing i look for
that freaks me out is the the the
bruised ankle or the bruised calves
bruised legs diabetes diabetes and what
if the blood just stays there
it's definitely not circulating it's too
much space for your little heart to
circulate things around with well
that's why at night it's very healthy to
put your ass against the wall and put
your feet upside down
and let that blood flow down to your
heart
and let your heart pump that [ __ ]
blood
and do ankle raises and once a week
instead of [ __ ] around that [ __ ]
volcano eating that cat food go over
here to lancashire during happy hour and
get the 25 massage and tip the guy five
dollars
tell him you want the neck leg and foot
massage
and he'll take all the fluid out of your
[ __ ] fat [ __ ] calves like he does
mine really because a lot of your stress
gets rested on your shoulders and also
on that front bone in your calf what's
that called dr henry right there and
your shin in the front right
a lot of times you go home and you put
your legs up and your shins are tight
you shouldn't have to get tight knocked
down
no doctor
dr melisa dr amy's my [ __ ] oh she's
your acupuncture talking to her mike
will you talk you're the she's your
acupuncturist right sorry about yeah you
don't call me that's dr ballista does
you have stress ever developed there
like my legs get it
not not on me i've had all kinds of
other things when i was stressed out but
this is really important like i had you
know i've had panic attacks like i've
had one or two never want to have those
again um
and
anyway my shoulders get it you know my
shoulders get it
and i get it there so you go over there
and leave 25 bucks you know what i'm
talking about right yeah like or
something like right on behind magnolia
right across just right across the
street from bank of america right a
little more there's a bodega there's a
pizza joint they make wings there's a
black hair color in place people will
have black hair going there and next to
that is a massage place that's legit no
hand jobs it's guys and chicks working
in there there's a chicken there
that's built like [ __ ] bolo
she's chinese and she's built like bolo
who's bolo bolo is the chinese guy and
then for the dragon okay and that woman
will give you a [ __ ] massage that
you're you'll beg for her to move in
with you
she ain't no beauty queen but once you
start squeezing your [ __ ] back
it's tremendous then they put your feet
in water
and while they're putting your feet in
water they do your shoulders your neck
your ears where is this right there in
lancashire you go down the [ __ ] block
to magnolia you hook a left to
lancashire and you hook a right on
lancashire and right on the [ __ ]
corner i'm going to go tell you what
it's called right now because that's the
type of [ __ ] i am all right
i'm gonna tell you people where to go
you have the loyalty card in your mind
yes i do
i in fact i got on my side like there it
is i got a free [ __ ] massage
and i'm working on the second one you
know why cause i take the wife in there
with me you think i'm [ __ ] [ __ ]
every time she complains about something
i take her in there for the small 50 and
everybody's happy
june foot massage massage for the head
shoulder and back
50 42
lancashire boulevard open seven days a
week 11 a.m to 11 o'clock at night be
nice to these when we go on dates
sometimes on friday nights when we're
here and go on date night right we go to
shorts to dinner and then we go there
we go there and not that night that's
the best date ever that's a date night
dog you know what are you [ __ ]
thinking i'm dealing with you just
because i'm a [ __ ] animal propeller
don't mean you know what i'm saying and
what we do is we eat and then we relax
for a little while then you go in there
because you don't want to get no massage
on your stomach when you have food in it
right it makes you want to [ __ ] that's
true this guy rubs your shoulders nice
he rubs your feet takes all the stress
out of your feet and then when you go
home you follow him saying everything
works out in your direction what the
[ __ ] you think you're dealing with at
least some [ __ ] novice here and the
whole thing cost you 50 bucks
50 bucks you tip the guy the small 10
and that little chinese woman you give
her 10 dollars she thinks it's like 2
200 dollars yeah who's the other chinese
woman do you think he is like an
assistant they have two chinese chicks
and two skinny chinese guys the skinny
chinese guys look like they haven't had
a meal in three [ __ ] years but they
will crack bones in your body you
haven't even heard before in your life
they're probably not hungry afterwards
they cracked my [ __ ] hip one day i
heard
and everything was dip top magoo when i
left there
that thing hadn't been cracked in like
22 [ __ ] years you understand me
that's what it's called the junk foot
foot [ __ ] tremendous and they cracked
my back they would do things to your
back they got a table and then they got
a [ __ ] they got the chair where they
put your neck in and they karate chop
you
then they got the chair that you sit
there and you soak your feet and you
look at the [ __ ]
tv screen
that's how we [ __ ] do it
and uh
you could watch [ __ ] lawn on as vu
i'm surprised you do you have a
one of the women help you or are you
okay with the guy massaging you oh man i
don't give a [ __ ] the guy is cool as
[ __ ]
fair enough that's very progressive of
each other you know what delete you
think like i'm [ __ ] around all day
i'm not [ __ ] around here
so i gotta hit the road
where you going
um i'm going back to venice
we'll sit for five minutes
i'm gonna wrap this up i'm gonna give
you a hug and a kiss
yeah
we'll talk about it later and this is
the new breathing book that's what you
have that one don't you yes i do okay
good but this one look at you you have
that one too look at you doctor i don't
know
that's not bad you got those cute little
chubby cuban feet
there you go there's some we got we just
got the new hit single right there
that's a new chapter in the book in the
next book
just got a little bigger than beat to it
and how we
anyway i'm happy you came in dr blaze
always a pleasure
you know i love you don't forget to take
the honor products yes that's why we get
sponsored bionic hopefully you really
enjoy we gave us some uh alpha brain we
gave us some shroom tech sport and we
gave her the hem force protein that's
the [ __ ] i [ __ ] live off i love it so
just remember if you want to get turned
down to hana go to honor.com
church boom and get 10 off delivered to
your house number two listen we all want
to eat better but when it comes to
snacks
we feel like the whole world is
delicious and a billion calorie versus
boring and tasteless i don't blame you i
do the same thing once 11 o'clock comes
i'm starving but let me include
something to you nature box has over 100
snacks that taste good and actually
better for you all snacks are made from
high quality simple ingredients which
means no artificial colors flavors or
sweeteners so you can feel good about
what you're eating
my favorites are the
chocolate nom noms the cheddar and hatch
chili crackers the salt and vinegar
veggie chips the white cheddar caramel
popcorn the list goes on and on and on
you're sure to find your new snack
obsession at nature box they add new
snacks every month inspired by real
customer feedback the latest food trends
and professional chefs it's that simple
so just go to naturebox.com choose the
snacks you want and nature box will
deliver them right to your door and
there's no risk if you ever try a snack
you don't like don't eat it nature box
will replace it for free here's what i'm
gonna do right now i'm gonna save you
some do-ray me nature box is all from my
family the church
three free snacks with your first order
when you go to naturebox.com
joey listen
i love smoking weed too you know what
i'm saying and nature box has always
been there for me give it a shot
columbus did naturebox.com slash joey
for three free snacks with your first
order again naturebox.com
joey number two talking about food this
is what this is what i do for you this
is why i set him up with the food dr
police
listen everybody everybody's in a rush
everybody wants to eat good that's where
blue apron comes in it's affordable
for less than ten dollars per meal blue
apron delivers seasonal recipes along
with proportional ingredients
to make
delicious home-cooked meals you choose
from a variety of new recipes each week
all right
and or let blue apron's culinary team
surprise you like they did lisa at least
lisa was having a piss he was jumping up
and down he was getting meals recipes
are not repeated within a year so you'll
never get bored
customize your recipes each week based
on your preferences blue apron has
several delivery options so you can
choose what fits your needs and there's
no weekly commitment so you only get the
deliveries when you want them each meal
comes with a step-by-step easy to follow
recipe card and pre-portioned
ingredients and can be prepared within
40 minutes or less so it's cooking
you're showering bam blue aprons fresh
this guarantee promises
promises that every single ingredient
and your delivery arrives ready to cook
or they'll make it right am i rightly
they hooked you up one of the best
things about blue apron is their
customer service it's it's
born on probably the best of any company
that i've ever dealt with and just on a
quick note my dad personally loves blue
apron so much he's upping it to the
family plan even though he's about just
him he loves it so much he's getting it
for every day of the week that's how we
roll here check out this week's menu and
get your first meals for free all right
let me tell you what we got salmon
cilantro with lime rice
uh uh
uh potato
catfish
potato crusted catfish with garlic
chives
red whole red white and blue pizza
can you imagine learning how to make a
red white and blue pizza i don't know
how to make that stuff blue april
teacher all right let me explain what
we're going to do check out this week's
menu and get three meals for free with
free shipping by going to blueapron.com
joey you'll love how it feels and taste
into creating incredible home-cooked
meals with blue apron so don't wait do
yourself a favor go to blue apron.com
joey right now again three meals for
free with free shipping come on where
you gonna get that deal try out
blueapron.com slash joey right now blue
apron a better way to cook i want to
thank dr belisse for coming in and don't
forget to get her book breathe
and the next one i can't tell you about
but breathe
is important
all right breathe is very important for
you that's the book that'll get you
started if you have questions where can
they email you dr belisa at the
breathing class this is what she does
this is what she [ __ ] does she
believes in my system give it a try
columbus did it right i love you dr
belize love you back don't forget this
thursday night the ice house [ __ ]
working out with uncle joey kick that
mule lee have a great week
well the first days are the hardest days
don't you worry anymore
when life looks like easy street there's
danger at your door
are you kind
[ __ ] dancers choice my friends better
take my advice
you know all the
[Music]
won't you come with me
[Music]
[Music]
have you seen the like
[Music]
is
[Music]
he's
come home
[Music]
[Music]
barely time to wait
[Music]
where does that time
[Music]
i can hear your voice
[Music]
[Music]
from here
[Music]
he's come to take his children home
[Music]
do
[Music]
oh
[Music]
got some things to talk about
[Music]
[Music]
children home
[Music]
[Music]